[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLE]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Welcome back to 8.20.
In this section, we're going to
talk about time, timekeeping,
and how to relate time between
two different reference point.
Now, let me start with a
quote by Albert Einstein.
"Everything should be as simple
as possible, but not simpler."
So let's start
with this in mind.
And recall that we
ended the last section
by finding that the wave
aether model doesn't really
describe electromagnetic
waves very well.
We see that there is a problem
between the experiments,
specifically the one
by Michelson-Morley,
and the theoretical
picture people had in mind.
So Einstein approached
this in an interesting way.
He simply postulated the things
he thought need to be true.
He said, "The same
law of electrodynamics
will be valid for
all reference frames
where all laws of
mechanics hold good.
This is the principle
of relativity."
The second postulate is that
"Light is always propagated
in empty space at the velocity
'c,' independent of the state
of motion of the emitting body."
So with these two
postulates, we will now
derive the theory of
special relativity.
And again, we'll start
by talking about time.
So time is suspect.
And I alluded to
this already when
we looked at Galilean
transformation,
where it simply, out
of our intuition,
assumed that time is invariant.
Now, when we now
talk about time,
the viewpoint I would
like you to have
is that we want to look at
clocks from different reference
frames.
We want to investigate
whether or not events
happen simultaneously or not.
What does it mean?
When we make a statement like
a train arrives at 7 o'clock,
what we mean is that there
is a simultaneous-- two
simultaneous events happen.
One is that this
little clock here shows
to point at seven
and 12, meaning
that it indicates to us
that-- this event indicates
to us that it's 7 o'clock.
And the second event is
that the train actually
arrives at the station.
So those two events
happen simultaneously.
The question now
is whether or not
two observers, one
stationary and one moving,
agree with this observation.
And I take it away--
the answer is no.
There is a relativity
of simultaneity,
meaning that two observers
can very much agree
on the description
of two events,
but not necessarily
that those two
events happen simultaneously.
So let's investigate.
And we use our two friends,
Alice and Bob, in order
to have this discussion.
All right, so we
start from a situation
where Alice and Bob
are both stationary.
Alice is on her
spacecraft, and she
has a device on her spacecraft
which shoots light or paint
balls towards two clocks.
And each time this happens,
the clock ticks, right?
And we just look
at one situation.
So she has a clock on the
left and a clock on the right.
Bob observes Alice's clock.
And he can compare this
observation of Alice's clock
with his own.
So in this station,
as to duration,
there's a TA and a TB.
Those are the times
of Alice and Bob.
Both are 0.
This is when the
situation starts.
And the capital T indicates
for Alice and for Bob
when they observe that
the clock has been hit.
I should add here that when
we talk about observation
in this entire class, unless I
make a very explicit exception
to this, we don't consider the
fact that observing actually
means that light has to
be emitted from the clock
and enters Bob's
eye in order for him
to conclude that there
was something happening.
The observation is like taking
an instantaneous picture.
OK, so we have to
keep this in mind.
But in this simple
situation, nothing is moving.
We can hopefully agree
that the times being
read for Alice and Bob on
the left and the right clock
are all the same.
Now, we go in the
second situation,
where we use the same
device but with a paintball.
So now, Alice moves and
Bob is observing her.
She moves with a
relative velocity, v,
and shoots off the paint
balls with a velocity, u.
The velocities will add, meaning
that the answers to clocks
are initially synchronized.
So there is a small tA
equals small tB equals 0.
Once the clock hits,
you can hopefully
agree that Alice
and Bob will agree
that the times when the left
clock and the right clock hit
are the same, right?
But now, we want to enter the
situation where we use light.
So we use a phaser in
order to do the very same.
So Einstein just postulated
that the speed of light
is constant, is c.
And it's the same in
all reference frames.
And it's independent
of the emitter,
which means that we cannot
add the velocities anymore.
So the velocity, as seen
by Alice, of light is c.
The velocity of the same light
by the moving observer, Bob,
is also c.
So here, we can conclude
that the times for Alice
for where the situation
is stationary, both clocks
will hit at the very same time.
Those two events,
clock one and clock two
are hit are simultaneous.
Why, for Bob, this is
clearly not the case.
You can see here that
this lagging clock
is being hit first, while
the leading clock is
hit a little while after.
So if Bob and Alice now meet
and they discuss whether or not
those two events
happened simultaneously,
they will disagree.
For Alice, those two clocks
were hit simultaneously--
at the same time for her.
But for Bob, the first
clock was hit first
and the leading
clock was hit second.
All right, we can
conclude the two events
can be simultaneously
to one observer
but not to another one.
This is rather confusing.
And we will see
and use this fact
a few times later on when we
discuss the famous paradoxes
of special relativity.
So let's look at this
in a concept question
to just make sure that
we're all on the same page.
Again, we discuss
your diagram three.
Alice move to the right.
Bob is the observer.
Alice's fires her
phaser at times equal 0.
Then the situation unfolds.
At time TA, capital
TA, Alice observes
that both blocks are hit.
At time TB1, Bob observes
that the left clock is hit.
At time TB2, it's
the right clock.
Which of the following
answers is correct?
So here, you want
to stop the video
and think about which of
the answers is correct.
So moving forward,
the correct answer
is number three,
where TB1 is smaller
than TA is smaller than TB2.
So again, the
leading clock lags.
The leading clock
has a larger TB,
which means that clock
ticks a little slower.
And again, the two events,
they can be simultaneously
to one observer--
Alice, in this case--
but not to another, Bob.
All right, let's look at
clocks a little bit more
and design an optical clock.
So here, the situation
is as follows.
We have two mirrors in
which we inject light.
The light travels
up and travels down.
And that's what
we call one clock
tick of this optical clock.
The length between
the two mirrors is L.
So for Alice, she has
this clock in her hand.
And she can happily observe
the ticking of the clock.
OK, Bob observes Alice's
clock and compares it
with his own identical clock.
There's a relative speed
between Alice and Bob,
and that's v in x direction.
Now, the task for you is to
relate the clock ticks which
are observed by Bob and
the ones which are observed
by Alice in Alice's clock.
So again, stop the video
and work out the algebra.
The answer is going to
be, again, surprising.
So if you do this now,
we find this picture.
So we calculate how long
does a clock tick take.
The light has to travel
to L with a velocity c.
So the clock tick is 2L over c.
The length can be expressed
as c times t delta tA over 2.
For Bob's, the situation is a
little bit more complicated.
And we have to use Pythagoras in
order to calculate the length.
So we define that the length
the light has to travel
is D, then the delta
tB as Bob observes
this is 2 times D over c.
Again, for Bob,
the light travels
with the speed of light.
Einstein just postulated it.
And then we find the length
as expressed to the time
as c times delta tB over 2.
The length in x is simply given
by the relative velocity, v,
times the time it takes
for the clock to tick--
v times delta tB.
So then we can express D square
via L squared plus x squared
over 4 and use those
expressions here.
So we just use this for L,
this for D, and this 4x,
we find this expression here.
All right.
And then we solve
this for delta tB.
And we find the relation
between delta tB and delta tA
and can find that it's
1 over square root
1 minus v squared
over c squared,
which is the Lorentz factor.
So we just used a simple
clock and Einstein's postulate
derived time dilation.
We find that for Bob, Alice's
moving clock moves slower.
Great.
So again, gamma is
1 over square root 1
minus v squared over c squared.
We often use, in short, beta
as a relativistic velocity.
It's unitless and
defined as v over c.
gamma is always
greater or equal to 1.
And it's mostly
one for everything
we observe in nature.
So in one of the p
sets and also here,
I invite you to simply
calculate values
for gamma for things you might
think are fast-moving objects.
So we start with a fighter jet.
We look at the
International Space Station,
the Earth around the sun, the
particle which almost moves
with the speed of light, and
the proton at the Large Hadron
Collider, which is only 3
meters per second slower
than the speed of light.
So again, stop the video
and work out those numbers.
You will need a
calculator for that.
So if I do this, I
find for this very,
very fast F15 fighter jet,
which moves with speeds of 2,680
kilometers per hour, that
the number for gamma is
1.00000000000, which
is 11 zeros, 3.
So we find this very, very
small number or number
which is very, very close to 1.
The duration for the
International Space Station
changes a bit--
only 9 zeros.
For the Earth around
the sun, the Earth
is really, really fast,
travels a long distance.
Every year, we travel
once around the sun.
And you know, every
year you get older.
You have a lot of
mileage on your back.
Here, you have eight zeros.
Particle which moves with
0.9 times the speed of light,
here the gamma factor is
very different from one.
It's 2.3.
And the protons we
have at the LHC,
they have a gamma
factor of 7,000.
So you see, once you get
close to the speed of light,
the gamma factor
approaches large numbers.
And that's where our
relativistic effects really
are visible.